the creation of the potato chip is a
rather snarky surprising and
idiosyncratic story
when french fries made their way to
america they soon became a restaurant
mainstay many restaurants served fries
as their signature dish believe it or
not they were once considered very
hoity-toity in 1853 george crum was a
chef at the moon's lake house in
saratoga springs new york their
signature dish was none other than
moon's fried potatoes or as the
aristocrats would say potatoes served in
the french manner
one day just like any other a customer
some believed to have been cornelius
vanderbilt himself ordered fries
upon being served cornelius scoffed and
sent them back he deemed the fries soggy
and not crispy enough this insanity
continued a few more times until crumb
lost it i mean he really lost it he
fired back cutting the potatoes paper
thin and frying them up you see back in
1853 eating with your hands was a major
faux pas making crumb's revenge even
more diabolical by cutting the potatoes
paper thin there would be no way that
cornelius could use his fork forcing him
to use his hands crump's plan backfired
kind of as the patrons dug in with both
hands and loved them
saratoga chips were born they became a
saratoga dining staple soon thereafter
they took the world by storm krom
himself even opened his own restaurant
with baskets of chips displayed on each
and every table